tomorrow the migrants according to Fox
News reporting are more than two months
away if any of them actually come here
but tomorrow is one week before the
midterm election which is what all of
this is about there is no invasion no
one's coming to get you there's nothing
at all to worry about when they did this
to us got us all riled up in April
remember the result was 14 arrests where
America we can handle it
but like I said a week to the election
and Jennifer Griffin's on it from the
Pentagon governor but we also at least I
haven't heard anything from any civil
rights leaders have you I heard I'll be
the King on a little while ago on our
air telling her to get people home that
this is not a way to solve any problems
but it seems like in the middle of all
of this to start picking on people for
civil rights and what they're saying and
what they're not saying we could we
could spend our time watching this and
reporting on it as we have it might be a
nice idea nice timing for one of the
higher profile civil rights leaders
who's to tend to come in after the fact
and say look how bad I'm sure with the
lease they came in now during the thing
saying hey let's let's let's call for
peace let's have some calm here that's a
wonderful idea I'm confident they're all
watching and we'll own your instructions
do exactly that what we really need now
is for it not to get dark before police
get control and if what they have is 42
state police and then 40 more to add to
the city of Baltimore's Police
Department that's not what's going to
happen so there's been no word on the
National Guard there's been no word on
how they plan to retake these streets
but we've watched the numbers here and
if police officers were to send people
into this crowd people would get hurt so
what is your alternative at this moment
I'm confident the police are trying to
figure this out but nobody involved not
the parents of these people not the
police officers and their families
nobody wants this to get to nightfall if
Baltimore can't take that you mentioned
parents where are the parents
well you know I've not been
the phone with them but if we want to
sit here and indict the civil rights
community and indict the parents for
what we're watching right now instead of
for now just covering what happens and
then later talk about whose fault it is
so we don't know these folks and I just
jump in chop no one's in dining anyone
we're watching the pictures we're asking
allah gentlemen questions a lot of our
viewers are probably asking the same
question
the question was where are the parents
surely you don't expect me to know that
now my question was civil rights leaders
where's al Sharpton where's Jesse
Jackson what we've got a major American
city that has decades of turmoil within
this neighborhood decades you heard the
stories from doug mackelway a little
while ago of people being arrested for
nothing of a violent crackdown for years
and years of them feeling powerless and
hopeless and nobody listening to what
they were saying 1/4 of the youth locked
up clearly there is a big problem then
all of a sudden an african-american man
is taken into a vehicle and he comes out
of it and dies and you get nothing from
authorities except a suspension and then
those who would do harm take an
opportunity to do harm and here we are
for the next few minutes I'm going to
give you the facts on Ebola it'll take
just three minutes but first today given
what we know you should have no concerns
about Ebola at all none I promise unless
a medical professional has contact
personally and told you of some sort of
possible exposure fear not do not listen
to the hysterical voices on the radio
and the television or read the fear
provoking words online the people who
say and write hysterical things are
being very irresponsible here are the
facts
a man contracted Ebola overseas
tragically he was dying in a Texas
hospital he was at his most contagious
while showing the most severe symptoms
that's how Ebola works but as we all now
know if you don't show symptoms you are
not contagious she did not show symptoms
according to the doctors you have to
remember that in the middle of all of
this you have to remember that there is
politics in the mix with midterm
elections coming the
and charge needs to appear to be
effectively leading the party out of
power needs to show that there is a lack
of leadership so the president has
canceled a fundraising trip and is
holding meetings and his political
opponents are accusing his
administration of poor chip for the
purpose of this fact dissemination
exercise those matters are immaterial
if you desert or commit treason you have
to be proof to have done so we can't
just decide because some people come on
television and yackety-yak and we had a
report of this and report of that that's
what happened as the Army said as the
Pentagon said you bring them home you
bring them home first and then you
investigate one thing is he's missing
you fixed that the other thing is their
allegations that he deserted or did
anything inappropriate then you
investigate that and let the chips fall
where they may
it ain't a soup how did they how do they
sleep at night after this vote on on
ground zero first responders from 9/11 I
are they gonna get that done or we're
just gonna leave these American heroes
out there to twist in the wind people's
feet to the fire when we you know we're
able to put a 15-2 new story building
down there so far at Ground Zero we're
able to pay for tax cuts for
billionaires who don't need them and
it's not going to stimulate the economy
but we can't give health care to Ground
Zero first responders who ran right into
the fire went down there the same people
and people know what this city was like
that day President Trump speaking from
the Oval Office in a short time there
will be a response from the Democrats he
made a number of claims there speaking
specifically about a murder rates among
those who are undocumented immigrants
the government statistics show that
there is less violent crime by the
undocumented immigrant population than
by the general population he called it a
crisis of the heart and soul he talked
about drug crossings for the border but
government statistics show much of the
heroin actually comes not over the
unguarded border but through ports of
call he talked about undocumented
crossings over the past the past months
in fact the number of undocumented
crossings over the southern border has
been steadily down over the last ten
years and the government reports that
there is more outward traffic than
inward traffic as for the trade deal he
mentioned with Mexico which he said
would pay
the wall that trade deal is not yet
complete and the president said that law
enforcement professionals have requested
the five point seven billion dollars its
he who requested it and it's he who said
he would own the shutdown
nevertheless he's making the case to
keep his base together on this matter
Chris Wallace is live with us in
Washington does that make the case Chris
for his base well it certainly does make
the case for his base the question is
that whether the base is enough and the
answer is it isn't because the Democrats
in an election in which the border wall
was a major issue took control of the
house and they have enough votes in the
Senate also to block any legislation
there
he also took aim today again today at
Amazon the post office is losing
billions of dollars and the taxpayers
are paying for that money because it
delivers packages for Amazon and a very
below cost and that's not fair to the
United States it's not fair to our
taxpayers and Amazon has the money to
pay the fair rate at the post which
would be much more than their thing
right now we're giving a subsidy to
Amazon and we're talking about billions
of dollars a year but the real cost and
a report just came out they said $1 47 I
believe or about that for every time
they deliver a package the United States
government meaning the post office loses
$1 47 so Amazon is gonna have to pay
much more money we know what's public
but we don't have a real idea of what
the 17 attorneys working for robert
muller have have learned have confirmed
we we do not but we know that the advice
that the president's lawyers gave him in
august this will be over by thanksgiving
is absolutely untrue here it is
Christmas and it's ratcheting up we also
know that there have been no denials to
the Washington Post reports this morning
that this is likely to go through 2018
and we also know that Bob Muller and
team are meeting with the president's
lawyers at the end of this week we don't
know what they're going to say who based
on the evidence based on what's happened
who's in the line of fire now Jared
Kushner Jared Kushner's in the line of
fire Donald Trump juniors and
and of course the presidents in the line
of fire we don't know what Bob Muller
has I am critical of a lot of our
colleagues who say there's no there
there
you know what Shep this is a jigsaw
puzzle with a hundred thousand pieces
and we see a piece here and a piece
there and everybody's it doesn't make
any sense they're not connected it takes
time to amass all these evidence all
these pieces of evidence so that we see
the jigsaw puzzle completed and that's
what Muller and company are trying to do
indictments and and confessions yes yes
yes look general Flynn was exposed to
sixty years in jail he had been
convicted of every charge that was out
there and even sentenced to the max he's
now exposed to six months how did he go
from sixty years down to six months he
must have given them something we won't
find out what that is until we get to
that point in the investigation but they
know Bob Muller knows we don't now
here's the accusation nine people
involved in the deal made donations to
the Clinton Foundation totaling more
than 140 million dollars in exchange
Secretary of State Clinton approved the
sale to the Russians a quid pro quo the
accusation first made by Peter
Schweitzer the senior editor at large of
the website Breitbart in his 2015 book
Clinton cash the next year candidate
Donald Trump cited the accusation as an
example of Clinton corruption Hillary
Clinton State Department approved the
transfer of 20% of America's uranium
holdings to Russia while nine investors
in the deal funneled 145 million dollars
to the Clinton Foundation that statement
is inaccurate in a number of ways first
the Clinton State Department had no
power to veto or approve that
transaction it could do neither we've
been told of a variety of stories we've
gotten and who knows if we're if we've
gotten to the end of the story we don't
have to be a knight now nobody else I
know that we have it because there's
news breaking at this moment Chris okay
Fox News can now confirm
two more Donald Trump jr. Jared Kushner
Paul Manafort the lawyer from Russia the
interpreter this new guy we found out
about today and a mystery person John
Roberts confirms there was an eighth
person in that meeting we don't know
there may have been more but there was
an eighth Jared Kushner filled out his
form
I think it's an f-86 saying who he'd met
with and what he'd done very important
stuff you can go to prison for messing
it up
you know intentionally he went back and
added 100 names in places none of these
people made it there's still not clear
we're still not clean on this Chris it's
if there's nothing there and that's what
they tell us they tell us there's
nothing to this and nothing came of it
there's a nothing burger it wasn't even
memorable didn't write it down didn't
tell you about it cuz it wasn't anything
so I didn't even remember it with a
Russian interpreter in the room at Trump
Tower if all of that why all these lies
what why is it lie after lie after lie
if you clean come on clean you know my
grandmother used to say when first we
practice to oh what a tangled web we
weave when first we practice to deceive
the deception chris is is mind-boggling
and there are still people who out there
who believe we're making it up and one
day they're gonna realize we're not and
look around and go where are we and why
are we getting told all these laws